numero 5 d'occidente vengono interessati
castori 29 salendo chiave più calendari
dell'avvento blitz nuova challenge con
la ruota
tantissimi i calendari dell'avvento
anche uno per cani e berlino quando lo
vedrà impazzirà berlino 5 o è arrivato
noi dovremo girare la ruota e la ruota
deciderà quali calendario del momento
dobbiamo prima di cose che berlino ea
volte dovremo scegliere da ventati o al
contrario il 3 ma ci sono state varie
cose se questo video l'assenza di 30
mila mi piace faremo anche la seconda
parte con altri calendari dell'avvento
quindi mi raccomando quindi facciamo
lato
mettetevi comodi prendete il pacco
carta forbice fatta di segni e l'altro
con gli dovesse year vitale che
calendario vado ad aprire annuale se ok
allora visto che sei una fan di harry
potter altri candidati della bozza il
calendario dell'avvento di harry potter
pronti alla botte 32 una briani lo ma
questo non è il calendario per te questo
il calendario di harry potter marino e
comunque curioso quindi mi assisterà in
questa apertura
iniziamo casellina numero uno che carino
guarda berlino 3 mag beach ed è un
portachiavi peluche senso per karina
seconda catalina sono cinque stickers
adesivi piccolissimi terza casellina
video non c'è niente una sapiente c'è
niente nella terza casellina sul pezzo
di pollo e si sono dimenticati di
metterlo forse è scivolato sotto dopo
controlliamo passiamo alla quarta
casellina lo vedete c'è il boccino d'oro
che si muove in taca velina
abbiamo un evidenziatore di tassorosso
mia testa caterina via
altri adesivi prima castellina
questo è il posto che per il cellulare
con lo stemma vivo qua ottava casellina
abbiamo un adesivo di stoffa dello
stemma corvo nero dove è un palloncino
da gonfiare con l'elio immagino per
farlo volare è contento di potermi
decima casellina ma c'è qualcosa di
strano
ah ok una pila quindicesima casellina
evidenziatore grifondoro rosa vedi se tu
potessi volato da qualche parte
recitativa ciardi si un altro adesivo
dello stemma e questo è lo stemma tasto
rosso o tasso fra su berlino sta
aspettando patteggiamenti pendere della
ventoux percario per averlo dentro una
collana con la saetta di harry potter
bella questa devo dire che per karina
tema di offerte verde o 22 st non a caso
perché non trovo le case vino in ordine
ci sono dei fermacarte con gli occhiali
di harry potter
dopo la saetta questo non so che cosa è
il simbolo dei doni della morte
poi abbiamo evidenziatore blu corvo nero
scotch washi tape con dei disegni di
harry potter blu carino evidenziatore
verde di serpeverde adesivo grifondoro
altri adesivi è un team brino con il
simbolo del bottino
e poi per ultimo abbiamo a ecco quello
che era scivolato e finito qua ed è sono
dei block notes con l'immagine della
mappa del malandrino che carini e
l'ultimo è una borsa riutilizzabile
busta borsa super carina con gli
occhiali e la saetta per carino e questa
è la mia corsa preferita che abbiamo
trovato in questo calendario e scrivete
nei commenti la vostra passiamo ora al
secondo l'autorità spiega abbiamo
comprato il calendario dell'avvento di
harry potter bergamo con l'acqua
harry lo sta cercando di aprire il suo
calendario senza che sia il suo turno
guardate ho cercato di mangiarlo
ecco qua il primo eri al ballo del ceppo
per conto
rimini castenuovo terzo rimontiamo tutti
quarto è una catapulta quinto questa
dovrebbe essere la mamma di malfoy se
non sbaglio fermate e giusto che cos'è
uno debba una decorazione a un
giradischi ottavo 11 12 14 17 un bel
piano 19 20 questo è complicato 21 22
hermione più bella 23 e prendiamo
l'ultimo cui abbiamo importarli che
cos'è
andiamo ora a votarli tutti ecco qua
tutto il calendario lego harry potter
montate o questi sono tutti i personaggi
con i vestiti del ballo del ceppo e qui
ci sono le varie decorazioni pratiche
carine anche decorazioni natalizie quasi
una calza itmi.mi castello
per carino devo pescarlo da ben prima
devo pescare la band ha un attimo per
mischiare questa da un ritorno che gli
eventi un attimo rischio bus tram quale
scelti prendo questo che cos'è frane di
scoprire subito cosa dentro numero uno
con mina il righello che non riesco a
togliermi per 4 a 1 block notes numero 5
vv abbiamo anna ma è una gomma oua prete
che carina gomma pastello a cera giallo
numero 7 un pastello certe numerata un
timbrino 09
un altro pennarello rosso numero 10 un
altro team brino si pastello a cera blu
rosso temperino a matita dei rizzi il
giallo un'altra gomma con annessa 8 e 9
abbiamo lo stesso la gomma ma questa è
fatta di gomma che carina enti
pennarello giallo gomila di 22 pastello
a cera rossa 3 adesivi di ola e l'ultimo
24 abbiamo
periodo d'oro è carino guidare scegli tu
certo questa è un calendario
dell'avvento dei the invece è un non è
proprio un calendario della ventura
mistery box di uno dei miei film
preferiti in assoluto che nightmare
before christmas fare nei commenti se lo
avete visto nodo vediamo come sono il
tempo ad enzo casellina numero uno
vediamo come queste ha un profumo di
dolce di cannella non vedo l'ora di
assaggiarlo apriamo ora la mistery box
perché tanto questo calendario saranno
tutti i te così non sia molto
interessante per voi
apriamo la mitri botta allora io ho già
pioggia stelli lui e il cagnolino quindi
spero che vi capiti mi piacerebbe lui e
che lui anche lui ma soprattutto jack
mettiamo kiss elettro dei bambini uno
del trio dei bambini che sono loro tre
che carino ha fatto benissimo con la
maschera da diavoletto h m t il kasami
non ero riuscito berlino che territorio
adelina numero 1 abbiamo dei biscottini
a forma di otto che carini
casellina numero 2 abbiamo altri
biscottini ma molto più grandi numero 4
non possiamo dargli tutti perché se noi
di parlare mangiarne quasi innanzi
abbiamo dei biscottini a forma di di
mariti numero 5 non glielo diamo adesso
perché stai lido questo adesso berlino
scappa e va a rossi cassano in un
angolino quindi diamo numero 6 altri
biscottini a forma di cuore dai merlino
titoli sfrutti la forma di cuore
vediamo se gli piace berlino buono però
7 berlino vuole distruggere tutto
abbiamo questi biscottini vediamo un po
questi cerchietti se vi piacciono a me
come berlino è buono ricevuto automezzo
numero 8 vediamo che siete carmelina
anni vito di leo pharma lotto
queste sono le provare una altri
biscottini piccolini berlino s'è messo a
rosicchiare sulla serie numero 11 si
guarda berlino che si sommi sentire
qualche c'è chi troverà davanti godi che
ci sia privo di 186 lutto che
cosa cercano altri biscottini a forma di
cuoricino nuovo bravo e molto paziente e
berlino perché lui vorrebbe mangiare
tutto il calendario dell'avvento
confronto il cartone che fa abbiamo gli
altri di sottini a forma di animaletti
numero 15 costruttive luglio dopo perché
veloce biscottini a forma di fiocchetto
la bellissima e 17 ai cerchietti dei
tributi minuti fatemi dove però di
piazza novelli numero di ghiaccio numero
18 giotti serie dai diavoli uno
stecchino il mio fisico
buona sera 19 berlino e per altre
stelline che c'erano buone non era un po
punti non erano buone numero 20
altri tutto giusto dire un punto come
avventura di cuoricini
numero 22 stiamo per finire ospiti
provera 23 penultimo davvero un gruppo
ma vicini e vediamo nell'ultimo cosa c'è
l'ultimo più buono altri fisco attivi
allora per finire diamo a berlino questo
che vi piacerà un sacco rosicchiarle di
boruc a popolo
facciamo un gioco viola nascondo vediamo
se berlino indovina dove papà e questa
presenza è buono se volete che apriamo
altri calendari dell'avvento lasciate un
bel mi piace fateci sapere qual è stato
il vostro calendario dell'avvento
preferito giù nei commenti e ora vi
lascio qua 4 caselline su cui cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella che proprie ditte buona
visione
ciao
per minuto